yeah because I even look at like the way
you handled the Flacco thing like
yesterday you were talking like you were
you were kind of being sympathetic to
his mental health bro because as a
person who've had mental health issues
you know what I'm saying if you ever
watch me I'll always talk about that
like I've had
super severe anxiety you know what I'm
saying
um once I stopped drinking hard liquor
man for like three four months I was I
was super depressed
um you know having insomnia like I just
feel like I was at a a [ __ ] terrible
point in my life and I know mentally a
lot of times man especially for somebody
like Flaco he's from North Dakota he you
know he don't he doesn't look like us he
doesn't act like us he does things that
are different but that you know he has
he takes so much [ __ ] hate and it's
like I think you know I think it all
really started once he uh he had that uh
moment with that dude who spit in his
face and you were sitting there like
I didn't sign up for this [ __ ] but even
even even that like that a situation
like that is like you gotta think about
that you get spit on you feel me got
everybody talking about you all the time
yeah for sure and it's like that [ __ ]
got feelings too you feel me and we
don't know mentally what he's going
through he seems like a nice guy and I'm
like you know God forbid something
happened to this man or he felt like he
can't take it no more you feel me yeah I
want to at least be like you know I'm
somebody that was nice to you you feel
me and I joke on them too like I say
certain things to him I call him I joke
on them I play around I troll him too we
all do that [ __ ] but at the end of the
day it's not to be malicious and you
know I I care about him and I care about
everybody on the team